en el marco de una preocupante crisis
alimentaria Rusia Busca fortalecer sus
vínculos diplomáticos en África de
visita en El Cairo el ministro de
exteriores rusos serguéi labrov quiso
tranquilizar a sus aliados árabes que
dependen de los cereales y de las armas
exportadas desde Moscú exportaciones
alteradas por la guerra en Ucrania
hemos confirmado el compromiso de los
exportadores de cereales rusos a
respetar todas sus obligaciones
nuestros colegas occidentales que se
toman muy en serio la situación actual
tienen que levantar los obstáculos que
ellos mismos han creado desde el inicio
de la invasión rusa de Ucrania la
inseguridad alimentaria aumenta en
África que importe en su conjunto El 40%
del stop de trigo de los dos países en
guerra la situación se agrava en Egipto
primer importador mundial de trigo que
compra un 80% del trigo que consume a
moscúlla kiev
Egipto ha estado claramente afectado por
esta crisis en términos de seguridad
alimentaria energética de inflación que
afecta la economía internacional y la
suspensión de las cadenas de suministro
son algunas de las cosas en las que
tenemos que trabajar
ya se encuentra en el Congo y
posteriormente visitará uganda y Etiopía
encuentros en un momento oportuno tras
el acuerdo alcanzado el viernes entre
Moscú y kiev para poder exportar las más
de 20 millones de toneladas de cereales
bloqueadas en los puertos ucranianos del
mar Negro y reducir así el riesgo de una
crisis alimentaria mundial sin embargo
el ataque ruso con misiles al puerto de
Odessa este sábado arrojó dudas sobre la
viabilidad del pacto